[Music]
you know cover my friend La La Anthony
getting candid about her famous friends
Serena Williams and Beyonce during an
appearance on Sundays watch what happens
live when a caller asked about John
McEnroe's recent controversial comments
about the pregnant tennis champ Lala
unapologetically slammed him for his
remarks oh I thought it was bull you
don't come from my friend like that I
didn't like that at all I mean she is
the best tennis player in the world I
don't care male female or other nobody
could see Serena Williams she offered
even more praise for Serena who is
expecting her first child with fiance
Alexis she's an amazing person she loves
kids she's great with my son she's gonna
be a great mom but the 38 year old star
was much more tight-lipped about her
notoriously private Powell queen-bee
when asked about the singers push party
what was serve amazing food I remember
it was like a backyard barbecue did you
know beforehand what the sexes were
absolutely not
it was blue there of course is blue
seemed pissed that she's getting sibling
what did you get the twins was Michelle
Williams there do we know why Kim K was
not there don't know that either okay
was Mathew Knowles there
[Music]
you